we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
totally different vibe today for
voicemail it's a very personal voicemail
segment take a listen to this
hey david um this is doggone from
atlanta georgia
i'm 19. and i just had a good question
about what you eat for breakfast
honestly i think you should start a
health
segment maybe or even
on your clips or something because
everyone everyone can benefit from david
tips well listen i am not going to give
any health advice here that i am not
qualified to do that and you should go
to i don't know who what doctor
nutritionist i don't know i will tell
you my typical breakfast repertoire we
need a break from the serious stuff
folks please don't come after me uh
don't don't go i actually get a lot of
questions about my breakfast
um i am not a big savory for breakfast
guy i'm sorry i'm not a big sweet for
breakfast guy i'm more of a savory for
breakfast guys so
sometimes
i'll have a croissant and a coffee all
right now i know the croissant is
somewhat sweet but that's like as sweet
as i would go
no marmalades jams preserves
uh or coolies on it whatsoever just a
plain croissant gotta be a good grit you
want crunchy on the outside you know
fluffy on the inside and a coffee but
more typically like at home i don't tend
to have croissants
typical breakfast for me
i will
uh saute up
a slice or two of turkey bacon turkey
bacon turkey folks not regular bacon um
and an egg over medium and then uh half
an avocado that's like a perfect
breakfast for me from the standpoint of
savory
and from the standpoint of
protein plus
healthy fats plus fiber it's really got
everything there
um sometimes now this this people know
about my
uh
love affair we fell in love with sweet
potatoes
and if i've got roasted sweet potatoes
from a previous meal as leftovers i will
sometimes take a sweet potato
and make some
vertical cuts
almost to get me
like an english muffin
size and shape
two little discs of sweet potato which i
will saute up
egg over medium on top of the sweet
potato almost like benedict
except instead of english muffin it's
the sweet potato
that's not bad
um
trying to think that's basically my i
mean it's some something like that i
might make avocado toast if i'm more of
a bread mood or something like that but
those are those are my breakfasts i am
not into uh i haven't had cereal in who
knows how long i'm a fan of oatmeal but
not for breakfast i like yogurt but not
for breakfast all right let's move on
because this is just a waste of
everybody's time i hope i've answered
the question sufficiently
on the bonus show today
european parliament calls for a flat out
ban on facial recognition some people
say ban the virus and get rid of it
european parliament is saying ban facial
recognition
in texas a man has been sentenced to 15
months in prison for posting covet 19
hoaxes on social media very serious and
los angeles has indeed approved that
strict coveted vaccination mandate that
on monday we said could be coming they
have approved it they have approved it
um i will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
it could not be simpler
you go to joinpakman.com
and you get a membership if you'd like a
discount you can use the coupon code
better21 and if you'd rather pledge via
patreon you can also do that by going to
patreon.com davidpakmanshow people
worried where was pat yesterday on the
bonus show pat will be back with us soon
just me on today's bonus show and
tomorrow pat will be back with us very
very soon uh after the columbus day
holiday
join today i'll see you on the bonus
show pat and i will see you very very
soon